If you don't have a goal,
you suffer.
And then you get cruel and bitter and
resentful and then you start to actively
try to make the world a worse place.
And so,
so because you can't suffer pointlessly
without becoming bitter and you can't
become bitter without becoming cruel.
So you need an eight.
The question is then the question.
You should David.
Yeah,
yeah.
Better aim,
that's for sure.
So then the question is,
what's your dream?
Hmm.
Welcome everyone.
Back to the school of greatness podcast.
We've got the legendary Jordan Peterson
in the house.
Good to see us,
sir.
Good to see it.
Very excited about this.
You've got a book out called 12 rules
for life.
Makes you guys check this out.
You've probably already got it,
but if you don't,
I'm telling you to go pick it up right
now.
An antidote to chaos.
Uh,
you've had so much attention over this
last couple of years and I've been
digging into the research and just been
fascinated by everything that you've
been up to.
And I just love your stance on the
vision you have for humanity in terms of
how we can all live better lives.
And I think you simplify a lot of things
in this book,
which some things people don't like to
simplify.
I like to complicate.
Hmm.
And I think that's what's gotten you a
lot of attention is that you try to
really simplify a lot of these things.
I try to make everything concrete so
that it's actually implementable.
Right?
I mean there's a lot of high level
abstractions in the book because it
ranges up into the theological and
philosophical,
but it's always grounded in what you can
actually do in your life practically.
You want to bridge that gap from the
highest steps,
traction down to the lowest level of
behavior so that it becomes
implementable.
And that's how philosophical concepts
take on their meaning.
Right?
Cause they have to,
they have to have some impact on the way
you see the world in the way you act in
the world.
Or they're not fully realized,
they're not understood.
Because partly what we mean,
I would say when we say that we
understand something,
it's kind of a state strange phrase to
but it means to be able to embody it in
a shift of view and a shift of action.
And then you've got it.
It's graspable,
it's in your hand and body.
Something in a shift of view,
mother.
Well they're the same thing because your
perceptions are very tightly linked to
your actions because of course when
you're acting,
you're aiming at something you have to
be devoted towards some,
some,
some aim,
some target,
right?
We play that out in sports all the time.
Yeah.
That's why sports are so entertaining
for people is because they dramatize the
idea of aim,
right?
And then not only of aim,
but of the pursuit of excellence in
pursuit of that aim.
That's the game.
And the reason it's a spectacle and the
reason that people participate in it is
because it dramatizes something
absolutely essential about life.
And so you want to take philosophical
abstractions and you want to use them
to,
to structure your aim and then your
perceptions organize around that aim.
And then you act it out and then you've
got it.
That's then,
then it's,
it's become part of your life.
It's not just an,
it's just,
it's not just a philosophical
abstraction that floats free in space.
Why is there so much conflict in the
world?
Is it because there's so many different
perceptions that people have what they
think should be,
right?
Well,
part of it is part of it.
Of course there's conflict because we
have real problems.
And so life is actually difficult
independent of the,
of psychological foolishness,
let's say independent of the obstacles
that we put in our own path,
like this judge,
it's already,
it's already fatally challenging.
Right?
Life is the ultimate challenge.
We will die.
Yes,
yes,
there is.
Well,
a challenge.
Yes.
Well,
fear,
pain,
all those,
yes,
all the things,
all,
everything that goes along with
suffering is a challenge.
And it's,
it's,
it's the full challenge because it takes
everything you have.
And so part of the reason we disagree is
because there are complex problems to
solve.
And then we also disagree because we're
willfully blind and because we're more
ignorant than we should be.
And we're not everything we should be.
And we tilt towards malevolence from
time to time and we betray each other
and ourselves.
And so we take a bad lot in many ways
and make it worse now.
Not always obviously,
and we don't have to,
but that's sort of the baseline that
we're working against.
And I think people are most disappointed
in life when they're disappointed in
themselves.
You know,
they see that they've made things worse
than they had to be,
even though the baseline can be pretty
brutal.
So yeah.
And so the book and all my lectures I
suppose are,
are,
are put forward in an attempt to take
the high level philosophical
obstructions and to make them into
something that's actionable and to take
the next best action in your life,
improve your life so we don't have to
suffer as much while.
And hopefully also so that people around
you don't have to either.
So one of the things I've been talking
to my audiences about is the
relationship between responsibility and
meaning,
which is,
what would you say?
It's a,
it's a constant refrain in the book.
It's one of its underlying,
um,
messages let's say,
or themes is a better way of thinking
about it.
Um,
you know,
if you start with the presumption that
there's a baseline of suffering in life
and that that can be exaggerated by as a
consequence of human failing as a
consequence of malevolence and betrayal
and self betrayal in dc to know all
those things that we do to each other
and to ourselves that we know that
aren't good,
that amplifies the suffering.
That's sort of the baseline against
which you have to work.
And,
and,
and it's contemplation of that often
that makes people hopeless and depressed
and anxious and overwhelmed and all of
that.
And,
and,
and they have the reasons,
but you need something to put up against
that.
And what you put up against that is
meaning,
meaning is actually the instinct that
helps you guide yourself through that
catastrophe.
And most of that meaning is to be found
in the adoption of responsibility.
So if you think,
for example,
if you think about the people that you
admire while you think about when you
have a clear conscience first,
cause that's a good thing to aim at,
which is something different than
happiness,
right?
Um,
a clear conscience is different than
happiness.
Yeah.
It's better.
That's better guilting yourself.
You're not feeling bad about your Isas,
right?
You feel that you've justifying,
you've justified your existence,
right?
And so you're not waking up at three in
the morning in a cold sweat thinking
about all the terrible things that
you've involved yourself in what you
said to someone that you shouldn't have
said,
or my,
you acted or lie the opportunity you
lost or,
or,
or yeah.
Or,
or the things that you've,
that you've let go that you should have
capitalized on and all of that.
And so if you think about the times when
you're at peace with yourself,
with regards to how you're conducting
yourself in the world,
it's almost always conditions under
which you've adopted responsibility,
right?
At least the most,
the most guilt I think that you can
experience perhaps is the sure knowledge
that you're not even taking care of
yourself so that you're leaving that
responsibility to other people.
Cause that's pretty pathetic.
And I,
unless you're psychopathic and you know,
and,
and you're living a parasitical life and
that,
that as a very small minority of people
and an even smaller minority think
that's justifiable.
But most of the time you're in guilt and
shame because you're not,
you're not,
not only are you not taking care of
yourself,
let's say,
so someone else has to,
but you're not living up to your full
potential.
And so there's an existential weight
that goes along with that.
So as you suffer even more,
when you don't take care of yourself and
take the best actions or do the work
that you know you can do,
and you rely on someone else to support
you financially,
emotionally,
physically,
whatever you know,
home,
whatever it may be.
Yeah.
Well,
cause you're not only,
you're not only not being what you could
be,
you're interfering with someone else
being what they could be.
Right.
So you're,
you're,
you're not only a void,
you're a drain Jesus.
That's a catastrophe.
And we usually don't even know when
we're in that situation cause we're in a
depressed state or where or we don't
want to see it.
You know,
you wake up at three in the morning and
you know,
and so,
and then you think of the people that
you admire yourself or perhaps you can
at least live with yourself when you're
taking responsibility,
at least for yourself.
And so that settles your conscience.
But then if you look at the people that
you spontaneously admire,
and so the act of spontaneously admiring
someone is the manifestation of the
instinct for meaning.
Right?
So,
and this is partly why people are so
enamored of sports figures because the
sports figures are playing out.
The drama of attaining the goal of
attaining a certain kind of,
let's say,
psychological and physical perfection in
pursuit of the goal.
That's the drama.
And to spontaneously admire that is to
have that instinct for meaning latch on
to something that can be used as a
model.
And then that model should be
transcribed into something that's
applicable in life.
You know,
and you really like to see in an
athletic performance.
You really like to see someone who's
extremely disciplined and,
and,
and in shape,
do something physically remarkable but,
and,
and to stretch themselves even beyond
their previous exploits because you
really like to see a brilliant move in
an athletic match.
But you also like to see that person
ensconced in a broader moral framework
so that not only are they trying to win
and disciplining themselves in pursuit
of that victory and then stretching
themselves so they're continually
getting better,
but they're doing it in a way that helps
develop their whole team.
And that's good for the sport in
general.
And that reflects well on the broader
culture,
a great leader and their team.
They're positive,
they're good sportsmen and against the
competitors and not negative towards the
other people.
They're lifting them up to like the
ultimate.
That's right.
So that they can,
they can work for their own improvement
in a way that simultaneously works for
the improvement of their team and that
and,
and for the sport and while,
and then to the degree that that spills
over into the broader culture so much
the better.
So that's all being dramatized in a,
in an athletic event.
And it's really,
it's not philosophical,
it's concrete,
right?
It's dramatized in the world and that's
what the game's represent.
And so,
well,
and it's partly because,
well in some sense life is a game.
It is,
it's in that you're always,
the analogy is that in in life,
like in sports,
you're,
you're setting forth the name and then
arranging your perceptions and your
actions in pursuit of that and that you
also,
we generally do it well,
cooperating and competing with other
people.
So that's also the game like element as
well.
All of that's dramatized in athletics.
That's like philosophy for people who
aren't philosophical.
And I'm not being smart about that
tonight.
It's like it really is philosophy for
people who aren't being philosophical
cause it's played out.
You know,
and you can see it too.
You can see the spontaneous appreciation
for the human spirit manifest itself.
When you see people rise to their feet
spontaneously in a sports arena,
when they see someone do something
particularly remarkable,
see an athlete who's extremely trained,
stretch themselves beyond what you'd
think is a normative human limit and
everyone celebrates that like
spontaneously.
So it's quite something to behold.
And so talking back to responsibility
and meaning when we're watching sports
or someone to do this act,
what does this do for us with in terms
of responsibility and meaning?
Well,
it,
it helps us figure out what we can
imitate.
Gives us a model.
It's a model as a model of something
that I respect while even what
philosophy is or even theology for that
matter is an abstract model.
Like it's laid out in words.
Now the problem often is,
is it becomes so abstract that people
don't know how to bring it back down to
total embodiment.
Yes.
Whereas something like,
like the drama of a sports event is sort
of midway between philosophy and action,
right?
It's so it's,
it's not entirely abstracted because
it's not only coded in words,
it's acted out visual.
You can see an example of what just
happened and you can try to reverse
engineer how they feel that,
yes,
exactly.
Well,
at least you,
the fact that you admire the person
means that you might start to try to act
like family.
Now it's not easy and maybe that would
mean maybe that would mean that you
start to discipline yourself with
regards to a particular sport,
but it might also be that you start to
mimic or at least affected in some way
by their,
their sportsman sportsman like behavior,
right?
Which is the ground of a certain kind of
ethic.
Because if you can play well with
others,
which is sort of the hallmark of a good
sport,
then that actually means that you're a
reasonably sophisticated and civilized
person.
It's really important to learn to play
well with others.
There isn't.
That's the ground of ethics and you can
do it there and that's setting.
Then hopefully you can translate it into
like,
well,
right.
That's exactly right.
That's my goal.
That's what you hope for,
right?
Yeah.
That's the goal of this.
So if the,
if the goal of the game is to put the
ball through the ball into the net,
then the goal of having games is to
produce people who can take proper aim
no matter where they are.
Right.
That's exactly what we're trying to do
with,
with athletics.
So,
um,
uh,
so I've been talking to my audiences a
lot about that,
about Andy Weil,
and there's more to it too because if
the background of life has,
is there's a,
there's an ineradicable component of
suffering and that's complicated by
let's say malevolence and the proclivity
of people to be trade themselves and
others,
which,
which complicates it makes it worse then
the,
if you don't have a noble aim and,
and,
and if that isn't imbuing your life with
sustainable meaning,
then you fall prey to all the
catastrophe,
the pain and the anxiety and the anger
that that's suffering generates.
And that makes you bitter.
Because what I'm hearing you say is
that,
and correct me if I'm wrong,
we must have an aim in our life,
no matter what stage of life we're in.
And if we don't have some type of aim,
even if for a few months of an aim of
going somewhere,
direction,
we're going to,
suffering is going to be even more
suffering.
Pointless,
because we're already going to face the
greatest challenges,
right?
You're stuck with 30 struggling.
That's right.
There's no way of diversity is coming no
matter what.
That's right.
We have big goals or small little goal
or whatever it may be,
but it's going to be the less suffering
if we have an aim.
Yeah.
Well not only that,
it's worse than that even because the
suffering is zero,
meaning,
well,
the suffering is pain and the suffering
is anxiety and uncertainty,
and the suffering is hopelessness.
But the consequences of all that is that
you get bitter.
And when you get bitter,
you get mean and you get cruel and you
start to hurt yourself and other people.
So it's not only that,
if you don't have a goal,
you suffer.
It's that you,
if you don't have a goal,
you suffer.
And then you get cruel and bitter and
resentful,
and then you start to actively try to
make the world a worse place.
And so,
so because you can't suffer pointlessly
without becoming bitter and you can't
become bitter without becoming cruel.
So you need an ame.
And the question is then the question,
of course you should aim.
Yeah,
yeah.
Better aim,
that's for sure.
So then the question is what should you
name be?
And we have a program.
It's one of the things I wanted to talk
to you about today.
I,
I have this website called self
authoring.com and that program helps
people write about their life.
And so there's a past authoring program
to,
to establish your aim.
You have to know where you are.
It's like you're trying to orient
yourself on a map.
You can't Orient Yourself on a map
unless you know where you are.
You'll also have to know where you're
going.
Right?
So those are the two relevant things.
The past,
our three program helps people write
about their lives.
So it's a guided autobiography.
We asked people to break their life up
into six epochs,
six sections and then to write about the
emotionally important events in those,
in those epochs and to detail out why,
why the positive things happen and why
more of that could conceivably happen in
the future and to detail out why the
negative things happened in to try to
understand why with a name,
to not replicating them in the future.
Because the purpose of memory isn't to
remember the past.
The purpose of memory is so that you,
you figure out what went wrong when
something went wrong so you don't
duplicate it in the future.
So that's the purpose of memory and the
past authoring program can help people
catch up and you know,
you have to catch up if you have
memories that are older than about a
year and a half that still cause you
emotional pain when you think about them
or if you dwell on them,
they come spontaneously back to mind.
It means you haven't,
it means that there's part of your life
that you haven't mapped out properly and
it still has emotional valence that's
gripping.
You should that story or it's still
holding on to you,
right?
Go,
yeah,
yeah.
Well you haven't been able to navigate
your way through it.
There's a pitfall there that you fell in
and you don't know how to avoid similar
pitfalls in the future,
and that's why your brain won't let it
go.
Cause it's saying that's what the
anxiety systems do.
It's like this happened to you.
It wasn't good.
This happened to you.
Fix It,
fix it,
fix it.
That will never go away unless you fix
it.
How do you fix it?
Well,
you have to figure out why it happened.
Right?
That's the first thing is like how did
you,
how was it that that situation arose to
pull you down?
And that's not simple.
That's why.
Well,
that's why we have the writing program
because it's complicated to think
through,
but you,
but if you face it and you,
and you meditate on it,
let's say and say,
and you do this voluntarily,
there's a pretty high probability that
you'll be able to decrease the
probability that will be repeated in the
future.
So
go ahead.
I don't want to say,
oh well,
well we,
that the second part of the program
helps people do an analysis of their
virtues and their faults.
Same sort of idea.
What's good about you that you could
capitalize on what's weak about you that
you need to fix so that it doesn't bring
you down.
Right?
And that's the present or three.
But the future authoring program is
probably most relevant to you and your
listeners because you're interested in
helping people establish aims.
And so we already talked about the fact
that you need an aim in life or,
or that's where you derive your meaning.
And without that,
things go to hell.
And,
and as literally as that can be taken.
And so,
but it's not easy to ask people to say,
well,
it's easy to ask them what do you want
in your life?
It's a very hard question to answer
cause it's too vague and grantee.
So we help in the future authoring
program,
we help people break that down.
So,
okay,
so here's,
here's the situation.
So you put yourself in the right frame
of mind.
So what's the right frame of mind?
It's like rural too.
In this book,
treat yourself like you're someone
responsible for helping your,
someone that you are responsible for
helping.
So what that means is you have to start
from the presupposition that despite all
your flaws and insufficiencies that it's
worth having you around.
And that it would be okay if things were
better for you.
So you need to take care of yourself
like you're taking care of someone you
care for.
So there's a bit of a detachment in
that.
And then the next thing is,
okay,
so now look three to five years down the
road.
Okay.
You get to have what you need and want,
assuming you're being reasonable and
that you actually want it to means
you're willing to make the sacrifices
that would,
that would make it possible.
What do you mean by reasonable?
Well,
that that's,
that's the next thing.
Well,
within your grasp,
that would be something is out of your
grasp,
but you still push hard enough,
then you need an incremental plant,
right?
You need to break that goal down into
steps.
Phrase goal within a year.
That's like,
yeah,
I haven't even done the work to mass
riskily yet.
Yeah,
I got it.
Yeah.
Well that's it.
And you can have a high end goal and
more power to you if you do need it.
Well,
you need a pathway to it.
If it's 10 stories up above you,
you need a staircase to get there.
Right?
And so you have to build the staircase
to,
and so in the future authoring program,
so you're asked,
first of all,
okay,
here's,
you get to have what you want and need.
That's the proposition,
but you have to imagine it.
You have to define it,
name at it.
So,
so then the first thing is,
okay,
um,
if you could put your family together
the way you wanted it to be,
what would that look like?
And so that might be your siblings and
your parents,
but that also might be,
you know,
your wife or your husband and your kids,
assuming that you're at that point in
your life could have the family you
wanted.
What would that look like?
Right.
Okay.
Career,
same thing.
You get to have the career or the job
that that is within your grasp necessary
and,
and suitable for you.
If you were taking care of yourself,
how are you going to educate yourself?
Because you're not as smart as you
should be.
There's lot more things you need to
know.
So you gotta keep learning and moving
forward.
So you need to plan for that.
How are you going to take care of
yourself mentally and physically?
Right?
So,
um,
how are you going to avoid that?
The catastrophic temptations for
example,
of drugs and alcohol because that pulls
a lot of people doubt and you need a
plan for that.
You're going to be a social drinker.
How much are you going to drink?
How much is too much?
What about your drug use?
Got to regulate that so it isn't a
pitfall.
How are you going to use your time
meaningful and productively outside of
work is needed to plan for that.
So that's um,
there's one other that that's a fixed
mindset,
right?
Yeah.
I think there are seven initial
questions and I don't,
I don't remember the one,
um,
oh,
intimate relationship of course.
So you have,
do you want,
do you want to longterm stable,
intimate relationship and if you do then
how would you like that to lay itself
out?
You got to have vision for that because
if you don't have a vision,
you're not going to aim at it.
And if you don't aim at it,
then you won't even see the
opportunities when they arise.
That's the thing that's so cool.
I wrote about this in chapter 10,
which is be precise in your speech.
It's a chapter about the fact that ame
structure your perceptions.
So for example,
once you aim at something,
your brain,
literally that perceptual structures in
your brain and your visual cortex
reorient themselves to calculate a
pathway to the ame and then what they
show you in the world is obstacles to
that path and,
and open pathways to the path.
That's actually how the world reveals
itself.
Just like,
just like when you're driving in a car
and you have a map and you or you aim at
a particular place,
then all the things that are related to
that place show up in the world,
it's exactly the same thing because you
are traveling through time and space,
right?
And you need a map.
And so,
so after you answer these seven
questions and you're encouraged to do it
badly because you don't have to get
perfectionistic,
just complete it,
right?
Because a bad plan is better than no
plan gives you something to improve.
So even if your aim is vague and even if
it's off target,
if you start aiming and you see you're
off target,
then you can shift and you can make it
more precise.
Start to recognize what you don't want
in that.
Yes,
exactly.
Exactly.
I thought I wanted this,
but I don't,
sorry.
Let me re navigate and figure out what I
do.
Exactly and you to have to try a bunch
of,
well you will have to,
you can be,
that's why you shouldn't get
perfectionistic about it.
You will absolutely be wrong,
but you won't be as wrong as you would
have been if you were aimless.
Right,
right.
So it's a,
so there's a bit of no man's land,
no man's land is norris.
Then go men's room is a bit worse than a
bad path.
That's exactly right.
Like that's a good one.
That's a good one.
And it's right.
It's right.
You don't want to be a no man's land.
Why did you use that phrase?
Because that's right.
That's exactly right.
I think
for me the idea of walking around
aimlessly is like the worst idea in the
world.
It's like zero purpose,
zero mission,
zero certainty at all.
It's like walking around in no man's
land right aimlessly.
But it's funny too because in no man's
land,
everybody shooting at you.
All right?
Cause that's a military term in no man's
land is the space in the middle and the
positions,
you bet.
So if you're aimless,
you're also at a place where everything
is shooting at you.
So it's a very good metaphor that came
to mind.
Yeah,
well that's why that worked on it.
That's very,
very cool.
So then we say to people,
okay look now,
okay,
now you thought about this for a while.
It's nice to do this over a couple of
days too,
because then you get to sleep on it and
that helps reorient yourself.
So then,
okay,
now you write for 20 minutes.
Don't worry about grammar,
spelling.
This isn't a,
this isn't a composition exercise,
right?
You get to have what you want three to
five years down the road.
What does your life look like?
Hypothetically?
Write it up.
Write it out.
Okay,
so then that's the first part,
the second part of exercise.
So now you've got your thing d that you
think,
well,
I'm motivated because I got my thing.
Do you think they map?
It's like you're not as motivated as you
could be because you don't yet have you
thing to run away from.
Because if you really want to be
motivated,
you want to be going somewhere and you
want to be not going somewhere else,
which typically is a pain,
right?
Yes.
Or pain or anxiety,
yet some,
some domain of suffering and guilt.
I don't want to feel this anymore.
Yes,
exactly.
Exactly.
So,
so the other thing we ask people is,
okay,
now take stock of your weaknesses and
imagine that you let them multiply.
You got hopeless and you ordered in and
things were as bad for you as they could
be in three to five years.
What are some examples of weaknesses
that people might have?
They lie,
they procrastinate,
they avoid their grandiose,
they're narcissistic,
they're undisciplined.
Uh,
there are nihilistic.
They're aimless.
All of those things,
right?
Um,
victim mentality.
They take the sh,
they take the,
the,
the quick way out.
They pursue and pleasures.
They sacrifice meaning for expediency.
They don't take care of their basic
responsibilities.
They fight stupidly with their parents.
They don't,
they don't negotiate properly with their
spouse.
They are bitter at work because they
haven't said what they have to say.
They haven't thought through what
they're doing tomorrow.
They drink too much.
They smoked too much.
They take too many drugs.
They don't regulate their there.
Yeah.
Everyone knows.
Everyone knows and everyone's got a set
of weaknesses that they know about and
so we say,
all right.
What are some of your weaknesses?
Like three weaknesses that you know
right now you could still work on it in
three things that you think are really
well,
a lot of things.
A lot of things are things that I've
taken care of in my life.
Like I used to smoke when I was a kid.
I smoked a pack a day.
I used to drink a lot.
I didn't work out like there,
there,
there I wasn't nearly as disciplined as
I should have been.
I wasn't just careful with what I was
saying.
Like I,
and I,
I suppose my most likely negative
outcome probably would have been,
I really liked to drink.
Like alcohol was a really good drug for
me.
I want you to do losses on that.
Um,
well partly it was mostly because the
opportunity came up for me,
uh,
to,
to investigate drug and alcohol use.
But I came from a little town in
northern Alberta.
It was a heavy drinking town and,
uh,
and uh,
that,
that could have been a real trap for me,
you know,
and,
and so anyway,
so we have these PPC,
okay,
now you know your weaknesses and you
know,
what particular hell you would descend
to if you allowed yourself to descend
into it because you've probably had a
taste of it.
It's like you really let that go and
you're in a terrible place in three to
five years because you haven't done what
you should do.
What does that look like?
It's like everybody writes that down.
Write it down.
So you know,
because one of the things you want to
have behind you,
let's say you have to do something
difficult,
like go confront your boss.
It's like,
well,
maybe hope isn't enough to encourage you
to do that.
You think,
well,
no.
If I don't encourage,
if I don't go confront my boss carefully
and intelligently,
right,
then I'm going to hate my job and then
I'm going to drink more.
Then I'm going to end up in that little
hell place that I designed for myself.
It's like,
oh,
I'm not going there.
Well,
I don't want to talk to my boss or I
don't want to confront my wife or my
husband,
whatever it is,
or my father or my children's for that
matter,
but if I don't,
then I'll resent myself or I'm going
down this terrible pathway.
It's like,
because sometimes when you moving
forward,
you have to do something difficult and
you might think,
well,
why bother and answer is well,
so I don't end up in hell.
How about that?
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah,
there's that deep.
If you don't experience the pain now or
the difficulty now,
you're going to have a deeper pain
later.
Yeah.
That's life.
Much deeper pain there and that's why I
think at you mentioned at one point is
like putting ourselves in um,
structured pain,
like structured in sense of feeling pain
throughout the day.
Whether it be the tough conversation,
I don't want to do that.
It's painful,
but I'm going to because I know
afterwards it's going to probably feel
better.
It's a bit of a sacrifice,
right?
So you sacrifice stability in the
present for a gain in the future.
That's the big discovery of human
beings.
Face works.
Were you a big athlete growing up?
No.
No,
but I know when I was a small kid and I
just skipped the grade,
although I skied and I went cross
country skiing and he didn't see
individual sports things.
Mostly with my dad.
You understand that and in order to
improve as an athlete or in any sport,
you have to put yourself through daily
pain.
Yeah.
Right.
If you want to achieve that model of
excellence that you watch someone
playing basketball as a child and you
see someone living this model is going
to be 15 years of deliberate pain.
That's a discipline that's it worked out
for a long time with weights,
you know,
so you know,
dealt it every day.
I didn't want to push through pain but
you knew that would get you a greater
result.
Yeah.
Well and it's easier not to do it then
to do it,
but not in the long run.
You know,
I really seen the benefits for example
for weightlifting cause I've watched
people cause I'm 58 50,
how old am I?
56 is a great,
you know what I'm seeing as I'm getting
older and I really noticed the
difference between people in when they
age,
um,
between people who laid down a good
physiological platform when they were
young and those who didn't.
Because by the,
if you haven't worked out weights
particularly I would say you start to
get pretty soft in your thirties and
your cardiovascular system starts to go
and really early.
They all,
the other thing too is the best thing
you can do to maintain cognitive,
uh,
ability isn't to do exercises like
lumosity.
It's not brain exercises that keep you
sharp.
It's exercise.
So if you're 50,
both cardiovascular and weight lifting,
if you're 50,
you can restore your cognitive function
to the level of a 30 year old through
exercise,
your mental function through physical
lights.
Yeah.
Well your brain is a very demanding
organ.
And if your cardiovascular system is
compromised,
then you get stupid.
And so,
yeah,
it's really cool because as you move and
the bigger you get,
the more stupid you'd become.
Mm hmm.
Yeah.
Well,
you compromise,
you compromise its function because the
brain is,
it's,
it's the organ that uses more.
It's,
it's very metabolically demanding.
And so if you're not in good physical
shape,
then one of the things that suffers most
greatly as your cognitive function.
And so that's quite an interesting thing
to see how tight that linkage is.
So in the next part of the program,
we have people,
now it's okay,
now you've got your vision.
Yeah.
Even if it's a bad one,
it's,
yeah.
That's right.
What's better than no vision at all,
right?
It's something that you could improve.
Well,
think you're trying to get through a
territory you don't understand and
here's your option.
No map a map that's not so good,
but has some things about it or a great
map while obviously the great map is the
thing you want,
but the,
the map that something is way better
than the map.
That's nothing.
Plus as you explore because of your map,
you can start to fill in the details.
You start to learn,
you just start to overcome stuff and you
start to master skills journey.
Right?
Yeah.
Well that's the other thing too is like
let's say you,
you aim at something and you and you
develop some skills along the way and
then you get like a third of the way
there and you think,
oh,
that's not for me.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
fair enough.
But now you've still got the skills you
developed.
You know exactly why it's not for you
now instead of vaguely don't have to
keep going after that.
Exactly.
Well and you have a rationale and then
you can bring that wisdom back even
though it's not perfect,
you can bring it back to your next plan.
And so take responsibility for the next
steps.
Yes,
yes.
And so as you plan,
you get better at planning,
which is the crucial thing.
So,
so then we say to people will take your
pause division and make it into eight
stateable goals.
Right?
So and then rank them in a hierarchy
because you need to know what like a top
goal and then yeah.
And incremental goals.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and that,
well that's the other thing is break the
goals into incremental goals so that you
have a reasonable probability of
succeeding.
So cause what you want to do,
this is also what you want to do with a
kid.
You don't tell your kid,
here is an impossible thing.
Why don't you go out and fail?
You say here's something worth going
after.
Here's the step you could take that
would push you beyond where you are,
but that you also have a reasonably high
probability of succeeding yet.
Right.
They'd call that in a timeframe.
Within some time frame.
That's the other thing.
You have to parameterize it with regards
to timeframe.
That's right.
And that puts you in the zone of
proximal development.
And that's a,
that's a concept that was generated by a
guy named [inaudible].
He was a Russian developmental
psychologist and the smart one,
that's where the idea of the zone comes
from to be in the zone.
And when you're in the zone,
you're expanding your skills at in a
manner that's intrinsically rewarding
because you're succeeding and so you
want to set,
if you're good to yourself,
you think,
okay,
I need to set a goal,
but I need to set a goal that someone is
stupid and useless as me could probably
attain.
If they put some effort into it.
And then you've got,
then you've got it perfectly because
it's not so high that it's grandiose or
impossible that you fail necessarily and
then justify your bitterness.
It's like,
well I could do well done cause that
happens to people all the time.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's like it's,
yes,
exactly.
While I set a goal and I didn't attain
it.
And so I'm not gonna set any more goal.
It's like,
no,
you set a goal that was inappropriate
for the timeframe.
Yeah,
that's right.
You didn't calibrate it properly and you
were playing a trick on yourself because
you want it to fail so that you could
justify not having to try.
So I'm being a victim.
It's just helpful.
You're still going to be a victim.
It's like there's no way out of that
man.
So you know,
because life is this life is a challenge
that in some sense can be surmounted.
So there's no way out of your problem.
But there is certainly proper ways of
dealing with it.
Yeah.
And so you lay out those eight steps,
lay them out,
and then the next thing is,
okay,
you need a rationale for them because
you're going to have doubts and other
gonna people are gonna put up obstacles.
Does that mean to me?
Is that a Mimi rationale?
Means A,
yeah.
Justification.
Yeah.
It's like,
okay,
so here,
what sort of justification is a good
justification for your goals?
It's easy.
Why would it be good for you?
Okay.
Why would it be good for your family if
you attain that goal?
Why would it be good for the broader
community?
Because if it's a good goal,
it should be good for you.
That's fine.
But if it's a really good goal,
it should be good for you in a way
that's good for other people.
Yes,
exactly.
And you,
and if you're going to decide what your
goals are,
why not set up the ones that benefit the
largest number of people simultaneous.
Yes.
If you can do that,
you should start with your own concerns
cause you have to take care of yourself
needs first.
Yes.
Put Your own oxygen mask on,
then put your child's oxygen mask on.
Yeah.
Right.
And then you can,
as you,
as you build up a,
the basis of competence locally,
you might develop enough skills so that
you can expand that outward.
And it also gives your goal a certain
amount of nobility.
And so if someone challenges you and
says,
well why are you doing that?
That seems stupid.
You could say I'm doing that because it
helps me take care of myself,
but it benefits my family.
And here's the reasons why,
and this is the repercussions out into
the broader community.
And like people aren't,
people who are putting up objections in
doubts aren't,
aren't armed to deal with that kind of
response.
And then when you have those doubts in
your mind that plague you,
which they go back to your reason to go
back to your reasons why it's right to
say,
why,
why am I doing this?
Oh yeah.
It's because,
well I have to take care of myself
because otherwise I'm pathetic and
useless and bitter and cruel and then
I'm going somewhere terrible.
So that's a bad idea and here's how it
would help my family and here's how it
would help the community.
And that's good enough set of reasons
for it unless I can think of better
ones.
Right,
right.
Without better ones.
That's good enough.
Because I think the question comes back
to after,
you know,
someone could go down the rabbit hole
and say,
why,
why am I doing this and why is this,
you know,
meaningful for me.
And I think a lot of people go back to
a,
why am I here on the first?
Yes,
yes.
Why am I here?
What is the meaning of my life?
And is this real or is this just some
dreamworld?
Well,
and then in that,
then people do go back to that and then
they get stuck on that.
Yeah.
What,
but none of this even matters because
why am I even here?
Well,
the thing is,
is that that's a self defeating set of
propositions in some sense because of
the consequence of being stuck.
There is no reason you stuck there to
begin with is because you're not very
happy about the fact that life is
intrinsically tied up with suffering
because he wouldn't be asking that
question to begin with.
Okay?
So if you let that pull you in and take
you down,
all it does is make the suffering worse,
not helpful.
And then,
and then the cascade that we talked
about happens.
You suffer stupidly and pointless.
You get bitter,
give cruel,
you make everything worse.
It's like that's your answer is it?
You're going to make everything worse.
It's bad enough,
you're going to make it worse.
Mostly people won't do that consciously.
So you think,
well,
what's the alternative?
Well,
here's one.
If you have a sufficiently noble purpose
to suffering will justify itself.
And I think,
I think that's empirically testable.
And I do believe it's the case because
I've watched people do very difficult
things like people who work in
Palliative care wards.
So all they're ever dealing with his
pain and death,
right?
And they can do it and get up in the
morning,
they go to work and they take care of
those people.
They lose people on a weekly basis.
And yet they can do it.
And what that shows is that if you turn
around and you confront the suffering
voluntarily,
you find out that you are way tougher
than you think.
It's not that life is better than you
think.
Life is as harsh as you think it might
even be worse,
but you are way tougher than you think
if you turn around and confronted.
And so then what you discover is that
there's a spirit within you that
pursues,
that can pursue something meaningful
that has the resilience and the strength
to contend properly with the catastrophe
of existence without becoming bitter.
That's actually the central.
So,
and then I would say that's one of the
central themes of 12 rules for life is
that make no mistake about it.
Like the first noble truth of Buddhism
life is suffering.
This is true and it's worse than that
because it's suffering contaminated by
malevolence.
That's the baseline.
But,
and so that's very pessimistic.
But the optimistic part is that you are
so damn tough,
you can actually not only deal with
that,
you can improve it.
It's like,
oh well that's a horrible situation.
But it turns out that I'm armed for the
task.
Well that's,
that's a great thing for people to know.
And I do believe,
I think the fact that we're armed for
the task is even more true than the fact
that life is catastrophe contaminated by
malevolence.
We're stronger than things are terrible,
so hadn't,
things are pretty terrible,
so that means we're pretty damn strong.
Wow.
Yes.
It's a very good thing to know and it's
not naive optimism.
It's a very different thing.
It's like no,
things are terrible.
They're brutal and you are so damn
tough.
You can't believe it.
So wow.
What's,
what's been the biggest challenge in
your life that you've had to overcome or
the biggest suffering that took you the
longest to get beyond to improve?
Having them bring you down is not
helping the person who has the problem.
It's the same with,
with my daughter.
It's like had my wife and I deteriorated
as a consequence of her condition.
A,
that would have been horrible for her
because then she would have had to bear
the weight of watching her illness
destroy her family.
Right.
Which have that killed.
Oh,
Christ.
Yes.
I mean,
that's one of the terrible things about
having a,
a very bad illness is that not only does
it do you in,
but you can see it taking its toll on
the people around you.
I think that might even be worse.
Hm.
Welcome everyone.
Back to the school of greatness podcast.
We've got the legendary Jordan Peterson
in the house.
Good to see you,
sir.
Good to see you.
And very excited about this.
You've got a book out called 12 rules
for life.
Makes you guys check this out.
You've probably already got it,
but if you don't,
I'm telling you to go pick it up right
now.
An antidote to chaos.
What's been the biggest challenge in
your life that you've had to overcome or
the biggest suffering that took you the
longest to get beyond
to improve?
Oh,
I think that was probably,
I wrote about this in the last chapter
of my book,
which is called Pedicab.
When you encounter one in the street and
it's about,
it's about dealing with,
you know,
when you think,
what's the worst thing that can happen
to you?
Well,
I think the worst thing is that you do
something really horrible and you screw
up your life in everyone's life around
you.
If that's yes,
yes.
And you have to live with knowing you
did it.
It's like that's rough,
man.
That's,
see it's worse.
Sky.
Yes.
Remember there are worse things than
dying.
Yeah.
Yes there are.
No,
no,
that's,
that's that bad thing man.
But,
but I think the,
the hardest existential situation that
I've been in is the situation with my
daughter because she was very,
very ill and she had rheumatoid
arthritis,
she had arthritis,
it wasn't rheumatoid type.
And she had 40 affected joints that it
started to bother her when she was two,
but really manifested itself fully when
she was six and some of the medical
treatment help.
But when she was 15,
14,
14 through 16,
um,
first her hip disintegrated.
Oh.
And then her.
And so she had that replaced after
walking around on it for like a good
year.
And then her ankle disintegrated on her
other foot and she had to have yet
replaced.
And so there were two years of
absolutely brutal pain for her,
like brutal daily,
excruciating pain.
And,
and we were really running around trying
to figure out what to do about it
because the hip wasn't too hard to
replace,
you know,
because surgeons are actually pretty
good at hip replacements,
but ankles are still so many bones.
Yeah.
And so,
and just watching that and,
and,
and while watching what it was doing to
her because she was in enough pain at
one point,
it just about broker.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
you and I,
you've probably been on a situation
where you were in pain for a night and
couldn't sleep.
It's like,
yeah,
fine.
So multiply that by five and extended
over two years.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
And she was on like huge doses of
opiates and so that was sedating her and
so that made it look drunk in public and
she can only stay awake for about six
hours a day.
And she had to take Ritalin to stay
awake because otherwise she was just
sleeping all the time.
And it was a very bad auto immune
condition.
And so it wasn't the only manifest in,
in the juke joint deterioration and the
pain,
because arthritis is also very painful
and 40 joints happens to be quite a lot.
So one joint was brewed.
Yeah,
right.
No,
it was absolutely brutal.
Beyond belief as a father or a parent,
how do you navigate that emotionally
yourself?
Yeah,
well that's what that chapter's about.
I mean,
so,
so what do you do when,
when things are too much?
Well,
one of the answers is you narrow your
timeframe and now they're answer is you
look for occasions of grace and beauty
where you can get the swelling had a dog
that really helped,
you know?
So that was something that was with her
all the time.
And we tried to put things in her life
that,
that she,
she could care for.
She had a whole raft of Pat's,
although she was allergic to almost
everything.
So most of them were lizards.
Yeah.
I know.
Get her getting up.
He's like,
Oh,
I love this Guinea pig.
And then,
you know,
three hours later she'd have a big
round.
We take the Guinea big Bi Harry's dog.
So the dog,
luckily the dog she could tolerate and
so we had the dog for her and,
but one of the things you do when you're
in a situation like that,
it's just a bloody ongoing nightmare,
is that you,
you shrink your timeframe.
It's like,
well what are we going to do in a year?
Oh God,
we can't even think about that.
It's about six months.
No,
yeah,
a week tomorrow.
Today.
The next hour.
Yeah.
So that's what you really do.
You shrink your timeframe until you can
tolerate it.
So you're not planning out year.
Cause then you'll go crazy.
There's too much uncertainty.
You just think,
okay,
how can I make the next hour the least
amount of awful possible?
That's what you do at someone's
deathbed.
You shrink your timeframe and that and
that's what you have to do.
How does that play into the,
uh,
the self authoring program?
If you have this vision for yourself and
you're mapping out a year,
two,
three,
five years ahead.
Yeah.
Well sometimes,
you know,
navigate.
Yeah,
that's right.
You have to read,
navigate.
You have to say no,
fit it into that.
Yeah.
Because even the best laid plans of mice
and men go astray.
You know,
I mean that's part of being a lot and so
you have your map,
but you know,
if you get a flat tire along the way,
you still have to stop and fix your car.
Maybe the bloody thing bursts into
flames.
You have to get a new car,
you know,
so I mean you're,
you're,
you're asset towards your goals can be
punctuated by unexpected catastrophe and
then,
well then hopefully you've made yourself
into a resilient person at that point.
And the catastrophe is no worse than it
has to be.
And you're not making it worse.
I mean,
one of the things we were fortunate
about is that by the time she got really
ill,
my,
my relationship with my wife was pretty
well together and my relationship with
my son,
my,
who's younger than her was also well put
together.
And so he was an absolute trooper men
because most of,
for a lot of his teenage life in
particular,
there was a huge amount of focus on the
suffering of his sister.
And we were like right up to here with
that.
It was just,
it was enough.
And he conducted himself admirably.
He didn't,
if he cause trouble,
we didn't know about it.
He kept it to himself,
you know,
and I don't mean he was hiding.
I mean he dealt with it and he spent a
lot of time at home and he didn't do any
unnecessarily stupid things.
And he put up with his sister and his
parents who were on edge a lot without
adding additional catastrophe and misery
and grief to it.
And when she was a little bit crazy and
was leaning on him too hard or bothering
him,
he was there to support her and it was
massively helpful.
And you know,
I wasn't any more,
my wife and I weren't any more crazy
towards each other then we had to be.
And so there wasn't like any additional
stress during those periods of time sunk
us.
Any extra would have been like,
yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
How are you able to compartmentalize or
just focus on your,
your career at that time?
You know,
lecturing or writing or whatever it may
be at,
well that's also part of the vision of
Hell.
It's like,
well,
what's the alternative?
You let things go and you make them
worse.
It's like not showing up and yeah,
just don't know.
There's no excuse for that.
It's like you can't you,
how did you say?
Was there a con compartmentalizing of
like,
okay,
it's nine o'clock or eight o'clock in
the morning,
I'm going to work and then yeah,
we made rules and we talked about some
of them,
like some of the rules were,
we didn't talk about my daughter
daughter's illness after eight o'clock
at night.
That was the rule.
It's like no sanity.
Well,
it's a war.
You wear yourself out in a week,
your dad and everyone suffers a lot.
So you've got to keep going through
however long this is going to be.
And so what?
What do you have to do?
What?
You have to sleep,
you have to sleep or things are going to
go bad.
Yeah,
that's right.
It's time to stop talking and go to
sleep,
so you have to cut off.
Yeah.
Well,
and I had learned some of that because
I've been a clinical psychologist for a
long time and so I've been dealing with
people's problems and you learn how to,
you know,
you think,
well,
how can you go home when when you have
all of those problems to contend with,
it's like,
well,
a,
they are not your problems not going
away right now and they're not going
away and and having them bring you down
is not helping the person who has the
problem.
It's the same with with my daughter,
it's like had my wife and I deteriorated
as a consequence of her condition.
A,
that would have been horrible for her
because then she would have had to bear
the weight of watching her illness
destroy her family.
Right.
We'd have that guilt.
Oh,
Christ.
Yes.
I mean,
that's one of the terrible things about
having a,
a very bad illness is that not only does
it do you in,
but you can see it taking its toll on
the people around you.
I think that might even be worse.
I mean,
this is gradations of hell,
but still,
that's,
so you also can't allow that to happen.
If you have a loved person around you
and they're ill,
you have a moral not to let it tear you
down because then it's on them.
That's no good.
Yeah.
And you think,
well,
how can you remain healthy and strong in
the face of the terrible suffering of
someone who's close to you?
It's like,
well that,
well that's it.
The alternative is worse.
You want me to get sick and get a
weighed and not be able to take care of
you or me?
Right.
And then we didn't,
we both drown faster.
Right.
Not Helpful.
What about,
did she ever go through a place over,
I guess,
I guess some people do this where you
know,
kids who have some type of autoimmune or
some type of disease or whatever it may
be,
they didn't necessarily,
you know,
they were born with it or aren't
happening somehow.
It's not like they ate something
themselves.
They weren't necessarily the responsible
to say,
right.
I mean,
was she responsible for causing all
these,
you know,
all the pain in her body or was it just
something that happens?
That's what we told her is just what
this life kid,
it's a lot.
It's not you.
We also told her very,
very many,
many times and we were very careful
about this.
Do not use your illness as an excuse.
As soon as you do that,
you can't tell the difference between
the illness and your character.
It's right.
So don't let it turn you into a victim.
Even though it's obviously it's a
catastrophe.
Like we were very clear about that and
that wasn't her fault,
you know?
But that she still had to bear up under
it as well as possible and to do
everything she could and not use it as
an excuse.
And we talked to her about that a lot
and we're clear about it because,
and I've seen,
this is one of the things I really
dislike about what the universities are
doing with disability.
It's like everybody gets a disability.
It's like well no wonder because people
have hard lives.
You know it's like it's very rare to
find someone who isn't suffering under
an undue load of some sort.
There's something wrong with them
or there's something wrong in their
family that serious or they have
terrible economic pressure.
Like there's something wrong.
It's like okay we should make allowances
for you.
It's like Oh yeah what allowances.
What exactly does that entitle me to
while I tell you,
man that's a murky place you do not want
to go because then you don't know
anymore.
It's like well what's my responsibility?
I mean I have this undue burden to bear.
Well how does that mitigate my
responsibility?
Well the answer is as little as
possible.
You don't go there cause you get
confused and,
and as soon as you get confused,
well then the illness is not only got
you physiologically,
it's got your psychologically and then
you're in deep trouble.
And so we were also very,
very key and to her great credit as far
as I can tell,
like I wouldn't say she never used her
illness as an excuse because never is a
lot,
you know,
or never is an extreme.
But she certainly was stood the
temptation to do it habitually and to
warp per character as a consequence.
And she did figure out what was wrong
with her and fixed it.
And so now she doesn't have any of
these.
She's healthy now while she still has
some residual damage from,
from everything that happened.
Like I just found out yesterday,
she went to Chicago to have her ankle
checked out because it isn't working
very well.
And they told her that she had to have
the old replacement taken out and a new
one put in.
So,
but,
but in her realm of catastrophe,
that actually constitutes not news.
That's not as bad as it could be.
So,
strangely enough.
So it's not like she's out of the woods.
But you taught her from an early age
that I'm sorry to cut you off.
No,
no,
no.
That even though she had a,
you know,
let's just for this state of the
conversation,
a physical disability,
right.
She wasn't as able bodied physically as
the majority of people.
Is that clear to say,
um,
that you told her like never allow that
to give you special privilege?
Well,
never allow that to be never,
no,
it wasn't that exactly.
It was never used that as an excuse to
not do something you could do even
without the thing.
Yes.
Because it's the,
there's a deception element there.
It's like,
well,
I don't want to do that and I have this
illness.
That's right.
Got It.
Don't use your illness as a means of
getting away with something because you
blur the line.
Constantly use that rest of your life.
Right.
And if you do that a hundred times,
you'll be so confused about what's
illness and what's,
and what's not that you'll not know.
You won't know anymore.
And maybe you won't be able to figure it
out again and then you're in a very bad
place.
You know,
there was some things that she had to
have done that were allowances,
like when she was doing exams,
she had to type because she couldn't
write her writing,
you know,
and she couldn't sit on the floor,
cross legged.
So she had to sit in a chair,
like things that she actually couldn't
do,
but she still didn't work.
Yes.
She did everything.
She said,
oh,
I can't take the task.
Yeah.
I can't do the exam at all.
But she was able to do it with different
circumstance.
Right,
right,
right.
And so,
and,
and the consequence of that was that
once she,
she figured out that most of what was
causing her,
what,
what was bothering her,
all of it by the looks of it was a
consequence of it,
a set of extreme sensitivities to almost
every sort of food.
So she hardly eats anything now.
So the only thing she eats his beef,
that's it.
Beef,
salt,
water.
That's it.
Nothing else.
Yeah,
that's it.
And she's been eating that way for,
well,
mostly for about three years,
but almost completely for a year.
And she feels fine.
She's 100% she has no symptoms and no
vegetables,
no supplements.
That's it.
Beef,
salt.
I'm serious.
Cause you never cheats.
Wow.
Never because she doesn't want to feel
pain and suffering.
Yes.
Well it takes it if she,
if she eats the wrong thing,
she has a terrible catastrophic
emotional and physical reactions for a
month.
Wow.
She essentially eliminate all food and
try one thing at a time.
And so that's going to work.
Let's do this.
And it took about three years to figure
it out.
So yes,
while I was right,
I can't,
it's absolutely beyond comprehension.
It's a diet that I follow almost,
almost entirely now.
Beef,
salted water.
Yes.
I'd been eating that way for about three
months and I'd been on an extremely low
carb diet for about two,
two and a half years.
Something like that.
Wow.
So,
cause I,
my,
both my wife and I have autoimmune
symptoms and she got all of them.
Your daughter.
Yeah.
So she got [inaudible] by a thousand.
That's right.
So and so,
but when she sorted out what was wrong,
she convinced me to also try what she
was doing and it's been extraordinarily
help.
Really need to.
Yeah.
So you know who would,
who would have guessed it?
So anyway,
so what you do when,
when things are too much for you as you,
you narrow your timeframe.
I also an enrolled in chapter 12 you
know what?
There's a,
there's a fair bit of discussion in
there about fragility and vulnerability,
which is really what you confront when
you have a sick kid.
It's like,
oh my God,
how can the world be constituted so that
a child can unfairly suffer in this
manner?
It's like,
okay,
here's a way of thinking about it.
All right?
Take away everything from your child
that makes them vulnerable.
Let's say I have a three year old.
It's like,
well,
three year olds,
they're kind of cute.
They run around there,
they're little in there and they're
vulnerable obviously.
But that makes them cute and attractive
and,
and lovable.
All of the vulnerability that's built
into that.
So you think,
well you move,
remove that one by one while they're
eight foot tall now and they're made out
of steel and there are parts of
replaceable,
they have artificially intelligent
brain,
like you replace them.
Obviously this is hypothetical with a,
with a superhuman robot that doesn't
die.
It's like fine,
but where's the three year old?
Right.
So one of the things I thought about
when I was writing this was,
you know,
when you love someone,
especially what,
you love them not only despite their
fragility but also because of it.
And so then that's the price he paid for
it.
It's like,
well you wouldn't,
they wouldn't be who they were if they
weren't,
weren't fragile and limited in their
particular way.
And the fact he liked to have them
around.
You Think,
oh well that,
I mean that gets,
you think that that fragility and
vulnerability is justifiable.
It's like,
well then you can't allow that.
It's re it's its existence to make you
bitter because he can't have it both
ways.
You can't have them being vulnerable and
cute and,
and interesting and,
and small and,
and,
and needing care.
But striving to,
to,
to develop and grow.
You can't have that without the mall.
So being prone to pain and destruction
and vulnerability and so yeah,
take your choice then what do you do it?
Teach them to be strong.
That's what you do.
You don't get rid of the vulnerability.
You teach them to be strong.
Yeah.
So,
and that's that.
That's also a theme that runs through
the book and in many,
many ways is that you don't protect your
children.
In fact,
you do,
you do the opposite.
You expose them to the world as much as
you possibly can and you make them
strong.
That's the best antidote to their
vulnerability,
not to protect them.
There's no protecting people.
We already established that life's a
fatal game.
There's no protecting people,
but you can definitely make them strong
and maybe you can make them strong
enough to transcend that.
That's the goal,
man.
So is there anything that you wish you
would've done differently with your
daughter or your son that you didn't do?
Not not have any grip.
Not of any great significance.
I mean I have,
I have wishes.
I suppose from time to time that things
could have been different.
I,
I spent less time on the positive
aspects of my son and my daughter
because we were contending with
catastrophe so frequently.
And so,
you know,
my,
both my kids have a variety of
interesting talents and it would have
been
better perhaps to have had the time to
develop those more thoroughly.
But you know,
when my son,
well he,
I wouldn't say he didn't get as much
attention as he needed.
He didn't get as much attention as I
would have liked to have paid him.
But by the same token,
and it isn't obvious that it's been bad
for it because it required him from a
very early age to grow the hell up.
And we relied on him right from the time
he was a young kid to make intelligent
decisions.
We assumed he would make intelligent
He was consulted with regards to
decisions and so,
and it also made them into someone who
is,
who is very self sufficient and capable
of taking care of himself.
So it might've been nicer for me,
I suppose to have spent more time with
him.
Right.
Um,
but,
but he lives down the street from me now
and I spend time with them and we have a
great relationship.
And so it's just,
it's,
you know,
and as he has a very good relationship
with his sister and uh,
so it turned out as well as it could
have.
Right.
So,
but that didn't mean that those years in
there,
they were brutal.
There was some brutal times.
Man is one night in particular.
Like she was in absolutely a absolute
agony and I couldn't get it under
control.
And I could see,
well,
because I am a clinician,
I could see,
I thought,
God dammit,
I'm going to end it,
end up taking her to Cam h as the
psychiatric hospital because it looks
like it's going to break out.
Really.
Like,
goddammit,
I couldn't see a way to resolve it,
but it pushed her right to the brink,
but,
but not over.
So,
and there was another episode after,
after she had her hip removed,
hip,
hip replaced.
She was put in a rehab home hospital for
awhile and she was the youngest person
in it by like 60 years.
And they treated her terribly,
it was a terrible place,
mean,
mean blind nurses and very,
very badly run.
And they traumatized her hospital.
It was a worse experience than the damn
surgery.
And so that,
that was,
that took her quite a while to recover
from,
but she did recover from it.
Do you ever think now,
um,
you know,
since you're a clinical kind of clinical
psychologist and you've done all this
research and work and studies,
do you believe that your daughter was
meant to experience this for you to kind
of test your ability to be with her?
And do you think she would have been
able to grow and the way she is now with
someone who didn't have the practice
that you had?
Well,
I think it was fortunate for all of us
that,
well,
my wife too,
my wife had worked in palliative care as
a volunteer and she was a massage
therapist for a long time.
She's very good at,
and my wife has a real,
she's a really tough person and if you
don't need help and you want it,
she'll cut you into ribbons.
But if you need help,
she will really help you.
So she's really good at differentiating
between people who actually need help,
in which case she is right there and
people who could stand up on their own.
And if you can't stand up on your own
and you could,
if you could stand up on your own end,
you aren't.
You don't want to be around her because
she will.
She will put you in your place.
And it was so funny because our kids
are,
our kids used to bring their friends
over all the time when they were
teenagers,
which we actually quite light.
And what we had a rule for the
teenagers,
which was,
we're really happy you're here,
but if you do something stupid and you
never get to come back,
that's actually okay with us.
Right.
And so they knew that and it was no joke
because we were happy they were there
and they were welcome.
But we were perfectly happy to dispense
with them if they misbehaved forever.
And so,
but what was really funny was that the
kids would come over,
the teenagers would come over and they
were pretty afraid of me to begin with.
But after being around for a couple of
weeks,
they were way more afraid of my wife.
So yes.
So that was very funny.
Yeah.
Because she's,
you know,
she's quite a pleasant person and she's,
she's not,
uh,
she's only five foot two.
So she's about,
although she's,
you know,
she's imposing enough cause she's also
in good physical shape,
but it was because I'm actually kind of
soft hearted and she's not softhearted,
although she can really take care of
people who need to be taken care of.
So,
no.
So I think,
you know,
mckayla had a fortunate,
fortunate circumstance in that sense
because both of us had a lot of
experience dealing with catastrophe.
And so when it came along we weren't,
we were overwhelmed by it,
but it wasn't because we didn't know
what we were doing,
we knew what we were doing.
It was just,
even though we didn't know what we were
doing as much as might be possible,
that doesn't mean that we could deal
with it because it was,
well it took us,
it took us one,
it must have been seven or eight months
to arrange the ankle surgery and there
was a waiting list in Canada at that
point of I think three years actually.
They wanted to fuse her foot,
which is really bad thing for someone
young.
And so we looked in India,
we looked in all Christ,
we looked all over the world for ankle
surgery,
like really everywhere.
And finally the government in Canada,
it was actually quite helpful.
We found a private clinic in Vancouver
that did the surgery and the,
and,
uh,
the Ministry of Health in Ontario was
quite helpful to us at that point.
But we were scrambling to,
well,
what,
what should we do?
Should we have her ankle replacement?
What sort of replacement?
Who did we talk to?
Well,
what about this waiting list?
Three years.
Like,
no way.
Shit,
man,
she can't live for three a week.
Oh yeah,
that's three.
Here's,
that was just beyond,
did you ever doubt yourself in terms of
your ability and your research and your
studies?
Did you ever say to yourself like,
man,
if I can,
you know,
figure this out,
then all of my work is for nothing?
Well,
no,
I never thought it was for nothing,
but I certainly,
I certainly doubted whether or not we
were going to be able to figure out,
figure this out.
Well,
because you thought it,
you know,
and at that time you're extremely,
uh,
educated research,
you know,
you'd see a lot.
Did you,
did that give you a fear of like,
well,
if I can't figure this out,
then no.
One of course,
of course.
Well her,
her prognosis was multiple early joint
replacements and that was like,
that was the good news because the bad
news is,
well how many and how many can you stand
and when does that kill you?
Like,
you know,
so her real prognosis was plenty of pain
with an early death,
you know,
because well even now,
even now,
you know,
like the surgeon who talked to her
yesterday said,
well because he talked to her about the
risk of amputation in the future.
It's like,
well this is the second joint revision.
It's like maybe this would last 15
years.
We don't know what the hell is going to
happen.
You well,
so our response to that is that's 15
years from now.
It's like,
who knows?
Well,
things are better now for how people
understand how to replace an ankle.
Then they were,
I think it was 10 years ago that she had
this one replaced and it helped.
It wasn't perfect.
Her hip is perfect.
The ankle has always been troubled,
but way less trouble than it was.
And so,
well you,
you struggle forward the best you can.
And so I suppose she could adapt to an
amputation if that was necessary.
But at the moment it isn't necessary,
but multiple amputations is not
something to really be looking forward
to when you're 16 you know,
and they were going to put her on
corticosteroids to control her,
her,
her inflammation,
and that would have produced cushing's
disease.
And so that makes your face all puffy
and it makes you gain weight.
And so it's very physically disfiguring.
So we decided not to go down that route
and wow.
Yeah.
Well,
but you know,
it's,
it's worked out.
Thank God it's quite the miracle.
And she had a baby a year ago and we
were never sure that was going to
happen.
So grads,
thank you.
Yes,
yes,
that's for sure.
So now we have this respite where she's
healthy and the last time I saw her,
she was looking great.
Like she just glowing.
She's so healthy.
I can't believe it.
It's just beyond belief.
And congrats on all the hard work you've
done to make a,
make it a possibility.
Yeah.
Well we avoided the worst excesses of
hell during the catastrophe.
So that's something.
And it did allow her the space to figure
out.
And my wife had always thought that diet
had a relationship to it.
And we investigated that.
Like there's a good literature that
shows if you have arthritic symptoms and
you stop eating if you fast,
they go away.
So That's interesting.
It's like,
well food must be causing it and see it.
Yeah.
But once you start to eat again to
survive what you eat,
it comes back.
It turns out no,
not no matter what,
almost no matter what.
Cause she sensitive to virtually
everything,
but she isn't sensitive to meet.
And so it turns out that if you eat
meat,
you can live.
Right.
So that's a big difference between being
sensitive to everything and not being
sensitive to one thing.
And so,
so it's,
it's a harsh diet.
Um,
it's made traveling difficult,
although I can eat in restaurants
because most restaurants can cook a
steak with nothing on it.
And that's made things much easier while
I'm traveling,
but
whatever,
it's working.
And so thank God for that.
Amazing.
Hmm.
Do you believe?
Do you think hypothetically if your
daughter was healthy and never had any
of these complications that you would be
the man you are impacting people,
that the success,
the,
you know,
all the attention you'd be getting.
Do you think you'd have as much
written 12th chapter,
that's for sure.
Do you think in general you would still
be able to have the ideals,
the belief,
the 42 that you have to reach people and
really impact people?
Yeah,
I think,
I think so,
but I,
I know what you're,
I know what you're saying.
You know your,
your question as well.
To what degree is adversity,
character building,
and the answer to that is plenty.
But I was already,
like I said,
it was the same with my wife.
We weren't naive people.
You know,
because I had an extensive clinical
practice I was dealing with,
with heavy level adversity.
Oh 25 hours a week.
Your daughter knows.
No,
but there were,
you know,
there were other problems in my family
and so forth that I dealt with as well.
And so we were already,
we'd already,
I think,
garnered most of what we could from
confronting adverse situations,
you know.
Um,
now did,
did that add a different level to it?
It's fine.
It probably,
it probably fire tested our
relationship,
our familiar,
it probably brought our family closer
together,
all things considered.
I saw the same thing happened when my
wife's mother die,
died.
She died of a pre frontal dementia and
she,
she developed it quite young about it,
started to really manifest itself in
early fifties and she died when she was
70 and she fell apart over,
you know,
18 years.
And she was very physically healthy.
Um,
and her husband,
who was quite the man about town when he
was a young guy,
real extrovert,
he was a real character in our hometown.
He took care of her so well.
It was absolutely jaw dropping.
Every time she slipped,
he'd step up to the plate and he,
he took care of her until he couldn't
lift her out of her chair anymore.
And he was getting old too.
And so she wasn't in an old age home for
very long.
And then we were around when she died.
Um,
you know,
over the last couple of days,
just before her death and her family,
her,
her sister is a palliative care nurse or
other sister's a pharmacist.
And tammy's had the experiences that
I've already described.
And then her father really stepped up to
the plate.
And so the whole family gathered around
for that.
And um,
they acted impeccably throughout it.
I would say they took care of their
mother carefully while she was dying and
they pulled together.
And one of the consequences of that,
which was so interesting,
is that although their mother died and
that was a terrible loss there borns
that connected them,
all of them strengthened to the point
where I would say that was almost
compensation for the loss of their
mother.
So that was really interesting to see
what happens even in a dire circumstance
if people do do what they can't.
No,
I'm not saying that that's going to work
for every situation because I know
people get cut off at the knees and
sometimes you hate a tragedy that while
it's fatal,
you know,
that you cannot rectify.
It's a real catastrophe.
But it was very interesting watching
that because they were alert and awake
around the deathbed and they weren't
fighting with each other at all.
There was no familial squabbling cause
you can imagine that that would happen
cause everyone's stressed and then you
can just imagine how terrible that would
make something that's already awful.
There was none of that.
They focus their attention on her,
you know,
they gave her water when she needed it
and they watched her and they made,
they made this terrible thing,
the least amount of awful it could be
and it definitely pulled them together.
That whole family including me is closer
because of what they went through and
also how they went through it and it's
probably the case.
Well I would say definitely advanced the
maturity of my son because he was cold
and I,
I told him,
look kid,
like you can't add anything to this.
We're,
we're,
we're up to here.
You have to conduct yourself properly
because otherwise everything's going to
shake and fall.
We can't have more of this.
You can't bring any and anything
unnecessary into this.
And it was an all star.
It was,
it was a remarkable man.
And,
and he who is only on grade 10 when
most,
most of this happened and your friends
are pretty damn important when you're in
grade 10 and he stuck around a lot to be
helpful.
So yeah,
it was really good for him,
man.
Yeah,
well he,
yeah,
he's a good character.
He's amazing.
He's,
he's quite,
quite something and it was very helpful.
He was very helpful to his sister.
They had their fights obviously.
Well and she was often unreasonable and
no bloody wonder,
you know,
well when you're strung out and you
can't feel anything but pain.
God,
she went through so much like even
watching her withdraw from the opiates
cause she was on them for about a year
and a half.
She just quit.
Hey,
they will,
as soon as she was done,
her surgeons like,
I'm not taking these anymore.
And she had formal medication,
which is the sensation of ants crawling
under your skin.
She had that for like a month and uh,
God,
unbelievable.
He was,
she just,
just sailed through it.
It's like I'm done with these.
Yeah.
You guys have been through a lot.
That's your lot here.
What's your biggest fear now moving
forward in your,
in your own life?
Oh,
making a mistake at the moment.
Cause like I'd be,
I'd been the subject of so much public
attention in the last two years and like
I've been in a situation where,
well,
even things I didn't say have also
almost been fatal because people take
them out of context.
Right.
You know,
and,
uh,
but I'm,
my biggest fear has been that I do
something careless and,
and that there are like serious
cascading consequences to feel like
you've done something careless or well,
everyone's done something careless.
Right.
You know,
but I've been pretty careful.
I mean,
I was fortunate,
so when this political scandal blew up
around me and in Canada,
when I opposed some legislation that I
thought was reprehensible,
he constructed,
um,
you know,
the,
the radicals on the left in particular
came after me hard.
And,
but I was fortunate because,
you know,
they called me every name under the book
and went after my character.
And you know,
I suppose there was some degree of of
that was understandable to some degree
because if you stand up against
something,
if you stand up against the radical,
right,
well maybe you're a communist might not.
Probably not.
Cause you don't have to be a communist
to not like the radical,
right.
But if you stand up against the radical
left,
well maybe you're a Nazi.
Well probably not.
But you might be.
And so it's certainly in the interest of
the people who are proponents of the
philosophy of the radical left to assume
that you're a Nazi because then they
don't have to deal with you.
And so that's what happens.
You throw yourself into the fray,
people try to localize you.
And they do that by saying,
well,
maybe you're this,
maybe this,
maybe you're this.
It's like,
well yeah,
maybe not too.
And,
and,
but I already had 250 hours of lectures
up on Youtube at that point.
So people could actually go and see what
I had said because virtually every word
I'd ever said to students in a
professional capacity,
not on every word because I didn't tape
every lecture,
but I taped multiple years of lectures
and so people went over those with a
fine tooth comb,
trying to find out if there's anything
I'd ever said that was,
and he couldn't find anything.
And that was because I'd been very
careful with what I say.
Um,
well,
ever since I was about 25 I started
paying attention to what I was saying
and not,
and trying very hard not to say things
that I would
try,
not trying very hard not to say things
that something in me objected to so and
well,
that seems to have been provided me with
a buffer.
And so people came to my website because
they were interested in,
well before the political stuff blew up,
I had a million views on youtube,
which isn't nothing.
1 million of anything is a lot.
But then when the political scandals
started to break,
yeah,
then people came for them but stayed for
the content.
And so,
and that's been really useful.
Yeah,
well it's,
well,
and it's not that surprising.
Well,
you know,
because of what you do,
it's like pe,
there's a great hunger for information
that is practical and useful and that
helps people find meaning in their lives
and orient themselves.
There's a great hunger for that.
And most of my lectures were derived
from solid psychology,
some of it experimental,
some of that biological,
some of it from,
from,
from the domains of neuroscience,
a lot of it from great clinicians.
It's not surprising that people find it
helpful because yeah,
well great clinicians were great because
they were really helpful.
And so to distill that into,
offer it to people in a digestible form,
to have that have a good effect on them.
While that's,
that's what you'd expect,
that's what the whole discipline is
about.
And so that's been,
that's been great.
These,
these public lectures that I've been
doing,
so I've think I've done 50 of them in
about 45 different cities now in about
three months.
And the average theater sizes between 20
503,000 people and they're unbelievably
positive events because people come
there and we talk mostly about
the political spectrum and why there's
room for voices on the left and why
there's room for voices on the right and
where the parameters of that should be.
Because both of those can descend into
extremism and that's not good at the
role of individual responsibility and
individual sovereignty and the necessity
for people to develop a vision.
The sorts of things that we already
talked about and virtually everyone
that's coming there,
they're not coming for political
reasons.
Even though that's the story you hear
from the more ideologically possessed
journalist types because they see the
world that way,
they can't imagine anything else could
possibly be happening,
but the people who are coming to these
lectures are coming because they are
doing everything they possibly can to
make their lives better so and so.
And it's lovely to talk to people like
that because it is great.
It's literally great school of greatness
baby.
Right,
exactly.
I've got six minutes to be mindful of
your time and your schedule and I want
to ask you three final questions if
that's okay.
Yeah,
you bet.
So as much as I would love for you to go
on for another few hours on these
answers so I can get to the last
question,
I'll do my best to be brief.
I wish I could go out longer,
so we'll have to have you come back as
time here in la.
Uh,
the first one is what is your purpose
now moving forward through everything
you've had in your life?
What's your purpose moving forward?
While I've,
I've specific,
uh,
I'm,
what's my purpose?
What am I aiming at?
Well,
I'm going to,
I did a series of Biblical lectures last
year.
I did 15 lectures on genesis.
I'm going to continue doing that.
So in November,
I'm going to start with the exodus story
is,
and what I'd like to do over the next 15
years is make my way through the whole
corpus of biblical writings.
So that's one major goal.
I want to write another book.
I,
I've written half of it already,
which will be a follow up to 12 rules
for life cause I actually had laid out
on a site called Quora 40 rules.
And so I'll do that and write in another
couple of books I suspect over the next
few years.
Um,
I,
the touring,
I'm going to continue,
I have 10 cities coming up in Canada and
another 20 in the u s and then 12 in
Europe and I'm going to go to Australia
in February and then back to Europe I
think in April.
So there's lots of touring on the
horizon and it's,
it's for the reasons I already described
and having,
I don't,
the lectures differ every night,
although there are themes that
constantly emerge and I'm using those as
an opportunity to have a detailed and
engaged discussion with the audience
about how we might proceed forward
individually and collectively so that we
can make things consciously better and
why that's associated with necessary
meaning and why that's a moral
obligation.
So it's a dialogue about
responsibilities and not rights,
even though right?
Rights are only important in so far as
they set up the space for you to
shoulder,
you're proper responsibility.
And as a sovereign citizen,
you have the responsibility for the
integrity of the state resting on your
shoulders.
And it's something that if you don't
take seriously,
then the state shakes and that's not
good.
And so I'm trying to convey that to
people.
It's like you have,
there's actually something that you need
to do.
You need to take care of yourself.
You need to take care of your family,
you need to take care of your community.
And if you don't do that,
then there'll be hell to pay.
And it's on you,
right?
Each of us.
And it's,
it's hard for people to grasp that while
they don't want to,
first of all,
maybe because they don't want the
responsibility,
but then they don't get any meaning,
then they suffer,
then they get better.
That's not good.
So it's like,
which of these are you going to pick?
But it's also salutary to people because
it's useful for everyone to know that if
you don't live up to your potential,
that you leave a hole in the fabric of
being and it's filled by something
approximating hell.
And unless that's what you want and you
shouldn't be doing that.
And so,
and it's perfectly possible to have a
serious discussion with 3000 people
about this and there are right on board
with it all the way.
And so that's really something amazing
to behold.
And one of the things I've realized is
all of these new technologies,
the technologies you're using enabled
these long form discussions,
turns out that people are smarter than
we thought.
Right?
Right,
right.
TV narrowed it,
right?
30 seconds say you're complicated thing
in 30 seconds.
Like,
like can't,
yeah.
And so we were viewing the,
the population through this narrow
window and everyone looked kind of
stupid.
It's like now the windows fully open.
It's like,
Oh look at that you people like 40 hour
netflix specials that are incredibly
complex,
right?
And you like three hour Joe Rogan
discussions that are complicated.
You'll follow the whole thing.
It's like,
oh good,
we're smarter than we thought.
Thank God for that because we better be
so.
So that's,
that's where I'm aiming at the future.
Got It.
Um,
okay,
question number two,
this is called,
you've got the 12 rules for life.
Make sure you guys again,
go pick it up.
Uh,
get it right now.
What's the link as well so far the
ring.com and I put up a code,
which is greatness,
donny percent off suite two for one.
So you can give the sweet to your
friends to self self authoring.com.
Yeah.
Not some.
Slash Green.
And that's just the code is the code is
great.
It's,
yeah.
And the thing that I would say to
everyone,
if you're going to try this exercise,
which I would recommend,
do it over a few days and don't do it
perfectly,
just do it.
Get it done,
do it bad first draft.
Right,
right.
Which is an important principle in life.
A bad first draft is a great thing to
have.
That's good.
Yeah.
You're also on instagram,
twitter,
facebook.
Yeah.
So we'll make all that stuff up.
Okay.
Yep.
And your website.
What's your main website?
Jordan B.
Peterson.
Dot Call.
Perfect.
Okay.
So make sure you guys get the book
subscribed,
everything.
Get the self authoring the future
authoring for you university students
out there.
Uh,
the future authoring program decreases
your probability of dropout.
If you're in a college program,
university program by somewhere between
25 and 50%,
especially if you're kind of aimless,
it works better if you,
if you already got a plan and you're
implementing it,
you've got a good direction,
then you know,
it's not as helpful because you're
already halfway there.
But if you're kind of lost and you do
this,
it'll help you not only establish your
goals but stick to them.
It really helps.
We've done three very detailed published
peer reviewed studies showing that this
really works powerful.
Yeah.
And it doesn't hurt you either.
That's the other thing.
That's great.
So that's great.
Uh,
you've got the 1204 five.
I've got something called the three
truths.
It's a question I ask everyone at the
end.
And um,
so we're gonna try and boil this down
for three truths for you.
Imagine this is your last day.
You get to choose the day for you when
you die.
Yup.
It's many years away.
He's one of the B.
And you've achieved your purpose.
Everything you set out,
you aim for,
you hit the target and then Yup,
you pass away.
It's the last day.
Everyone's there.
It's a celebration.
Yeah.
But for whatever reason,
there's no more videos of you up online.
There's no more lecturers,
no more podcasts,
no more books for whatever reason,
you'd have to take them with you.
So no one has access to your
information,
but you get to a piece of paper and you
get to write down three things you know
to be true about your life that you
would pass on.
I like to call it the three things that
make you weak.
I'm one.
Hm Hm hm.
Lift your eyes above the horizon and aim
at the highest star that you can
contemplate.
What's the third one?
Put Your family in order.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Powerful.
Before I ask the final question,
I want to acknowledge you for a moment,
Jordan,
for your incredible wisdom and
vulnerability with me.
We just met.
But I feel very connected to you and
your mission and your purpose.
And uh,
I just appreciate everything you've been
through as a father and as a husband,
um,
for your,
for your daughter,
for your son,
and for your wife to continue to move on
in your own dreams and pursuit of
bettering humanity while going through
all that you've gone through.
So really knowledge,
everything you've been doing and what
you stand for and your ability to use
your words carefully to make sure to try
and make the best impact on people who
are listening.
So I'm like acknowledge you for all of
that.
I hope we get to have you come back
sometime when you're in la cause I think
we can go for another hour or two.
Um,
and the final question is what's your
definition of greatness?
Okay.
Well,
greatness is what reveals itself when
you,
okay.
When you attempt to formulate,
when you attempt to carefully articulate
and live out what you believe to be
true,
it just happens because there isn't
anything more powerful than truth,
right?
That's the antidote to suffering truth,
So it's a strange thing because you
think,
well,
yeah,
it produces a lot of suffering too.
It's like,
yeah,
in the short term.
Yeah.
So,
yeah.
Awesome.
Thank you,
sir.
You Bet.
Thanks for the invitation and the
opportunity.
Very nice to meet you.
Yeah,
thank you.
All right.
Okay.